[Musique]
14 novembre 1921 le docteur frederick
banting et ses collègues de l'université
de toronto publié un article
scientifique qui va mener à l'un des
plus grands succès de médecine moderne
le traitement du diabète
à l'époque il est difficile de soigner
cette maladie qui se traduit par une
concentration trop élevée de sucre dans
le sang tout ce que les patients peuvent
alors faire est de restreindre
sévèrement leur alimentation
hélas la majorité meurt des suites de la
maladie
déjà en 1889 des chercheurs allemands
découvrait que des chiens dont on avait
retiré le progrès ans devenait gravement
diabétique ce indiqué qu'une substance
sécrétée par le pancréas permettait de
prévenir le diabète
la substance en question est une hormone
produite par des sections bien précise
du pancréas appelées îlots de langerhans
cette hormone permet aux cellules
d'absorber le glucose le sucre sans quoi
celui-ci s'accumulent dansant
[Musique]
dans les années qui suivent des
chercheurs essaient d'administrer des
extraits de pancréas par voie orale ou
par intraveineuse à des patients
diabétiques mais sans grand succès
pour parvenir à un traitement efficace
il faudra donc isoler cette hormone
ces défis qu'espère relevé le docteur
frédéric baltique
[Musique]
pendant des mois les chercheurs
travaillent sur des chiens d'abord à
thouars leur procédure consiste à
ligaturer les canaux du pancréas ainsi
l'organe se détériore et ils parviennent
à isoler annie l'eau de la garonne
cela permet de recueillir la fameuse
hormone qui sera nommé insuline qui
vient du latin une sous là où il
allait t 1921 l'équipe du docteur
banking réussi à réduire la glycémie
d'un chien diabétiques en lui injectant
de l'insuline prélevés sur un autre
chien
dans les mois qui suivent avec l'aide du
biochimiste james crowley les chercheurs
transfert cette découverte sur des
patients humains
les résultats sont saisissants
[Musique]
les honneurs ne se font pas attendre
moins de deux ans après leur découverte
frederick banting agent cloud se voit
décerner en 1923 le prix nobel de
médecine
aujourd'hui l'insuline est produite en
laboratoire à partir de micro organismes
elle est devenue un des traitements de
choix pour les personnes diabétiques
sa découverte a permis de sauver des
millions fille
[Musique]
m